HILLARY CLINTON, TONE IT DOWN,
IT'S NOT RIGHT.
>> Laura: THANK YOU SO MUCH,
GLAD TO HAVE YOU BOTH BACK.
IN THE TYPE OF NONVIOLENCE WE'VE
BEEN SEEING FROM THE LEFT, IT'S
NOTHING NEW.
THE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA WAS
LOOKING IN THE 1960s AND HE
HAD HIS OWN WAY OF DEALING WITH
THE PROBLEM.
JOINING US NOW WITH,
PRESIDENTIAL HISTORIAN CRAIG
SHIRLEY.
I'VE BEEN DYING TO TALK TO YOU,
AS THE TEMPERATURE IS RISING.
YOU GET THE SENSE ESPECIALLY
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA, THAT'S A
BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN NOW AND
IN 1969, PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO CALL
LISTS, CAN COALESCE IN A PLACE
REALLY
FAST.
HOW DID REAGAN DEAL WITH IT AND
HOW MIGHT WE LEARN FROM THAT?
>> HE DEALT WITH IT WITH A LOT
OF WIT AND GRACE.
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR HE WAS
CONFRONTED BY A SMELLY,
MALODOROUS, DIRTY AND DISHEVELED
HIPPIE.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN BILL CLINTON,
BUT THAT HIPPIE WAS CARRYING A
SIGN THAT SAID, MAKE LOVE, NOT
ROAR, WAR.
HE TURNED TO HIS AID AND SAID HE
COME FROM THE LOOKS OF HIM, I
DON'T THINK HE WOULD DO EITHER.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
>> IN BERKELEY AGAIN THERE WAS A
GROUP OF UNRULY STUDENTS OUT
THERE, ANTIWAR PROTESTERS.
THEY WERE MAKING A SCENE AND
MAKING THEMSELVES OF OBNOXIOUS.
REAGAN WROTE ON A PIECE OF PAPER
AND PUT IT UP TO A SHEET OF
PAPER AND SAID, I'M SELLING MY
BONDS.
HE HAD A WAY OF DEALING WITH
THESE THINGS BY TURNING HUMOR TO
HIS ADVANTAGE, WHICH CAN BE A
GREAT ASSET IN AMERICAN
POLITICS.
>> Laura: IF YOU'VE SEEN TRUMP
IN RECENT DAYS OF THESE RALLIES,
HE'S ACTUALLY BEEN EXTREMELY
FUNNY.
AT THE SAME TIME, IT'S A
DIFFERENT AND ENVIRONMENT
MEDIAWISE.
THE MEDIA WAS AGAINST DRAGON,
BUT THERE IS SOMETHING DIFFERENT
ABOUT THE WAY THE CLIPS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA ARE SHARED.
THIS IS FROM 1969, AND THIS IS
IN A PUBLIC MEETING WITH THE
BERKELEY ADMINISTRATION DURING
ALL OF THE CHAOS ON CAMPUS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> ALL OF IT BEGAN THE FIRST
TIME SOME OF YOU WHO KNOW BETTER
AND ARE OLD ENOUGH TO KNOW
BETTER BUT THEN PEOPLE, YOUNG
PEOPLE THINK THAT THEY HAD THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE THE LAWS THEY
WOULD OBEY AS LONG AS THEY WERE
DOING IT IN THE NAME OF SOCIAL
PROTEST.
>> IS NOT APPROPRIATE FOR
TODAY'S TIME?
YOU CAN TRASH SOMETHING AND PULL
DOWN A STATUE BECAUSE YOU DON'T
LIKE IT.
GET THE MIDDLE FINGER TO THE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE SOMEONE GAVE
YOU THE LINES TO SAY?
>> HE BROKE IT DOWN TO HIS
ELEMENTS, TO HIS COMPONENTS.
IT WASN'T JUST ABOUT SOCIAL
JUSTICE BUT ABOUT CREATING
INJUSTICE.
THIS IS THE ESSENTIAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TEA PARTY OF SOME
YEARS AGO AND THE PROTESTERS OF
TODAY.
THE TEA PARTY WAS DEFENDING
INSTITUTIONS AND THE PROTESTERS
OF TODAY ARE TRYING TO TEAR DOWN
INSTITUTIONS AND THAT'S THE
ESSENTIAL DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
TWO.
>> Laura: I THINK YOU HAVE
HEARD FROM SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE GOTTEN IN
THE FACES OF THE SENATORS, AND
THEY SAY THEY WANT TO TAKE IT
ALL DOWN.
THERE WAS A PIECE IN THE POST
TODAY BY ONE OF THEM.
THEY WANT TO TAKE IT ALL DOWN,
NOT ABOUT WINNING A PARTICULAR
POINT OR AN COURT SEAT, IT'S
ABOUT TAKING THE ENTIRE
FRAMEWORK WHICH IS JUST PUSHING
AGAINST MINORITY GROUPS IN THEIR
VIEW.
>> WE ARE FACING THE 21ST
VERSION OF THE FRENCH REVOLUTION
WHICH AS YOU RECALL WAS ABOUT
TEARING DOWN ALL INSTITUTIONS IN
FRANCE AND DESTROYING
EVERYTHING.
MARRIAGE, CONTRACTS, MONEY,
GOVERNMENT, PROPERTY,
EVERYTHING, IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
AT THE TIME WHAT THEY CALLED
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
AND THAT IS WHAT THE MODERN LEFT
ANTI-PROTESTERS ARE ABOUT, IT'S
ABOUT DESTROYING ALL FABRIC OF
SOCIETY IN ORDER TO START OVER
AND EVERYBODY SUPPOSEDLY STARTS